a new report on the death of an unarmed
black man after an encounter with police
finds the officers who stopped him
were wrong 23-year-old elijah mclean
died following the confrontation in
aurora colorado back in 2019
now a panel of medical and legal experts
found crucial mistakes by officers and
paramedics
ultimately led to his death omar
villafranca is
in aurora and spoke with mclean's father
what must he be thinking this morning
omar good morning to you
good morning elijah mclean's family says
the report basically confirms what
they've been saying the whole time
that the aurora police department and
medics violated his basic civil rights
and they tried to sweep it under the rug
and now they want
justice for those who are responsible
stop i have a right to stop you because
you're being suspicious according to the
independent investigation
aurora police in fact had no legal basis
to stop
frisk and violently restrain elijah
mcclain
the findings offered little comfort to
his father lawain mosley
he was loved and he is very missed he's
missed
oh my god he's very much missed mcclain
was heading home from a convenience
store in august of 2019
when he was stopped by officers
answering a 9-1-1 call about a quote
sketchy man in a ski mask i am an
introvert
these respective boundaries that i am
speaking i'm going home
relax or i'm going to have to change
this situation the report found
that none of the officers articulated a
crime that they thought mr mclean had
committed
or was about to commit stop fighting us
i can't breathe correctly instead
officers put the 23 year old in a tight
neck hole
then paramedics sedated the 5'6 140
pound mclean
with enough ketamine for a man weighing
50 pounds
more than he did all without conducting
anything more than a brief
visual observation he suffered a heart
attack on the way to the hospital
and died days later
sparking protests across the nation i
just
wish they could have did something
different better training
better everything compassion
the report is calling for changes on how
the police department handles use of
force cases
including improving training and
accountability systems but mclean's
family
is demanding more what does your version
of justice look like
fire they shouldn't be police officers
shouldn't be paramedics period
i think you should go to jail you killed
a young man yes
should be held accountable the report
also criticized the aurora police
department's
initial investigation into the incident
saying they didn't even ask basic
questions and the questions that they
were asking
helped to exonerate the police officers
now the three officers involved were not
fired for this incident also the state
attorney general
is asking a grand jury into to look into
possible charges
for those three officers anthony omar
thank you it's just so clear
elijah mcclain should not have died
elijah mcclain should not have been
stopped not have been stopped and when
you hear the more you hear the worse it
is
i didn't know he weighed 140 pounds but
it reminds me remember the mass shooting
at the aurora
theater james holmes shot 12 people
injured 70 others
and he was arrested without incident
he's in jail